hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
video game crossovers have been around
since the early days of gaming and every
year more companies decide to merge with
another franchise to create either a
triple-a masterpiece
or a gaming monstrosity in the old days
Super Mario could be found refereeing
high stakes boxing matches on his day
off from plumbing and more recently the
God of War himself Kratos stopped
brutalizing gods to try a spotter in
this video we're going to focus on the
crossovers which make no sense at all
but kept us enthralled all the same here
are 6 video game crossovers that are so
wrong they are so right
[Music]
[Music]
monster hunter is a franchise dedicated
to slaying anything from dinosaurs to
flying albino backs and the occasional
dragon - it's all about planning and
preparation eating before a hunt to
attain a buff and sharpening your weapon
often for prime damage figures
what kind of crossover could improve
this experience how about Ryu from
Street Fighter
it may sound ridiculous but that's
exactly what's happening right now in
monster hunter world Street Fighter 5
players can get their hands on the
Hadouken master and take him on a hunt
to fight a great bear off or maybe even
an angina
there are even emotes available to buy
which allow him to Hadouken and show
Duquesne the living daylights out of the
wild life Sakura can also join Ryu and
live out her monster hunting fantasies
too before heading back to Street
Fighter 5 monster hunter world has
numerous crossovers planned even ps4
exclusive techno dinosaur hunting a loin
from horizon zero dawn has emerged as
yet another monster hunter what on earth
could be next maybe Frank west from the
Dead Rising series I don't know about
you but I can't wait to find out
the ape escape series started on the ps1
back in 1999 and by the ps2 days they
were big business starting off as a
third-person platformer in which we hunt
down and save our monkey brethren by the
third installment the crossover was
announced which baffled many gamers
Metal Gear Solid was brought on board
the gameplay mirrored what you'd expect
from a typical Metal Gear game but was
simplified for a younger audience
the final battle even takes place on top
of a wrecked Metal Gear just like in
many mgs titles ultimately they used ape
escape as a vessel to promote Metal Gear
Solid and it worked a treat many young
gamers progressed to Metal Gear Solid
and looked back with fondness so what's
our reward for completing this crossover
quest
how about Solid Snake and monkey snake
sharing a roll monkey by the way we
haven't yet I'm just make you can call
me that from now on and you keep
interesting a pair of snakes nice to
meet you
snake the end as a quick side note Metal
Gear Solid 3 subsistence caps this
unlikely partnership alive with a
minigame where snake tracks down monkeys
against the clock
New York pizzas the best am i right
two words beef bourguignon you really
have lost your mind fighting games are
renowned for cameos and strange
crossovers Street Fighter and Tekken
have been leading the way but injustice
too has taken videogame crossovers to
another level injustice is all about
superheroes beating the living hell out
of each other to see who's the ultimate
combatant
it's obviously Batman right in just
these two brothers sub-zero from Mortal
Kombat to face Batman Hellboy from the
comic book two-face Batman shove it up
your ass all right I agree a little bit
too much fat man but now injustice is
bringing in a group of teenagers to take
on gods amongst men luckily these are
teenagers who are also mutants with
ninja training and their green TMNT the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles against
Superman what could go wrong when did
you get nerfed us what's really
impressive here is the intros and the
outro dialogues which personalize each
encounter Michelangelo even throws in
video game references I'll end it with
one punch only if you got cheat codes -
oh and for you oldies like me there's
even a TMNT call back to the original
cartoons
[Music]
[Applause]
injustice to keep that up
Bravo is it possible to get a video game
crossover into a tennis simulator smash
court tennis was a hugely strong
franchise before it started to tail off
but smash court tennis pro tournament -
that's not easy to say decided to switch
things up by introducing characters from
Tekken and Soul Calibur Heihachi Mishima
is known for his desire to murder his
own family and dominate the world and
pretty much beat anyone to a pulp
wearing a massive diet you win well it
turns out that he likes to take on the
tennis pros in his spare time
[Music]
this is the same two four characters
from Soul Calibur Cassandra in
particular who's abandoned her sword and
shield in favor of a racket
the one thing we can learn from this is
that tennis is the ultimate battle nah
maybe not Ghost Recon wildlands is an
open-world tactical shooter in which you
head an elite group of badasses sent to
take down the Santa Blanca drug cartel
you wouldn't think a crossover would be
possible here after an update in late
2017 a new icon became visible on the
map visiting this new point of interest
will treat you to a few dead bodies and
a bloodied woman with the greatest lip
syncing since milli vanilli it killed
them it killed them all it you mean here
no eat large um blah the jungle in
commonness it came alive he'd reached
out and took them to Infierno that's
enough of that
guess the crossover yes let's check out
the other clues we have a lovely crop of
skinned dead bodies hanging from the
trees nearby next we have a beautifully
kept skull and spine collection Jesus
you guys seen this know where machete
did that to surgical to clean there is
even an alien spacecraft here to be
found what on earth am I looking at here
finally the green fluorescent blood
trails expose the movie crossover we're
no longer hunting drug runners we are
fighting the predator the film came out
in 1987 and it really does stand the
test of time watch it if you haven't
already if only for the swats [ __ ]
one-liners the attention to detail in
this videogame crossover is staggering
with the same soundtrack and very
similar dialogue to invoke the right
feelings
ever dealing with it bleeds and if it
bleeds we can kill it
the fight itself is so freakin tense as
the predator can briefly hide from
thermal optics and seemingly teleport
around the jungle
I still haven't won the battle but when
I do I'm expecting the predator to do
something he did in the movie I've
already said too much
quick get to the chopper so sorry I'm so
sorry
the 1990s saw one of the greatest
console wars in history with Sega and
Nintendo going head-to-head with the
Genesis or Mega Drive if you're from the
UK going up against the SNES the Super
Nintendo Entertainment System both
companies had established their leading
characters with Mario and Sonic
the console war was so bitter that Sega
in particular with fire shots at
Nintendo constantly trying to get the
edge in the market for your columns
brief last time past Nintendo inevitably
eclipsed Sega throwing them out of the
console market completely not even the
brilliance of the Dreamcast could help
their demise
now without Sega as a direct opponent
the gates were open to a Mario and Sonic
team up you may be thinking they go up
against Robotnik and Bowser in an epic
faceoff to rescue a princess or two or
maybe the ultra delectable Amy for well
they decided to go for a spot tie-in and
sent Mario and Sonic to the Olympic
Games they've done it five times in fact
the games are a blend of insane button
bashing and controls finesse to see who
would win between a blue hedgehog an
overweight plumber a turtle ox thing and
the greatest villain in videogame
history while Luigi oh and did I mention
Amy you go girlfriend Hedgehog thing
strut your funky stuff so there we have
it six videogame crossovers that really
shouldn't have worked but they bloody
well did what's the strangest crossover
or cameo you've ever played if we get
some funny ones I'll make another video
and give you a shout out I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
like always I'll see you next time
[Music]